you ever been struck star struck by
someone you have worked with we
mentioned that but who's the biggest one
who's the one that you're like that I've
worked with yeah
man Sean say me it was me I was gonna
say Christopher Walken for sure yeah he
was intimidating because he's also I
mean he's just awesome but he's uh he's
also intimidating he is he is oh yeah I
remember uh
we I just would watch him on set when he
was working on this movie pool hall
junkies this little independent and I I
remember
just the way he said lines like the line
was they're playing pool and he says
you know they're gambling and he goes
you know been at all
and he goes
and then walk and says how about the
ring Joe he says how about the ring he
wants his ring
and and Paul materi says
the ring you want the ring
and I remember walking if you read the
line it would have been like well you
said it Joe bet it all you said it and
he goes you said it Joe
bed at all
oh my gosh just the way you said it Joe
that at all
just it goes down it goes up it's just
like what the [__] is he doing and it's
genius and he's like he was weird he was
weird but I loved him but he [__] with
me hard on the The Rundown wow what did
he do there's three times that I
remember the one I told the story before
but like I remember just walking off
from set and I saw him and he's standing
in front of his trailer he just kind of
kind of looked sad and I was like man
yeah Christopher Walken looking sad by
his trailer so I walked over to him and
I and forgive me because I had I have
told a story before but it helps with
the other ones but like I didn't know
what to call him like Chris or
Christopher wait a minute I I told the
story
yeah did you say did you say his full
name
yes I said
I sort of got it I said go tell the
story tell it sorry for interrupting but
no no no but yeah I I so I would always
call him Christopher Walken
did you call him Christopher Walken no
Tell Your Story start over I'm gonna cut
that out cut that out Jason I'm an
[__] say it again go ahead no no so I
walked up to him and I was like hey
Christopher Walken are you okay and he
goes I can't do his voice so let's do
mine but he's like yeah I am I'm good
I'm good
I'm a little sad you know it's my
birthday so I'm like holy [__] dude it's
your birthday I'm [__] gotta get
these people to get you a cake or
something he's like no no no
I don't want a kid
I'm just kidding it's not my birthday
I'm like what he goes yeah it's on my
birthday I was like what the [__] wait
and then like an hour later I hear
people singing Happy Birthday
and bringing him a cake
oh no he what he said was he goes
because it's not my I didn't I didn't
say we got to give him a cake he goes
when he admitted it wasn't his birthday
he goes it's not my birthday like he was
like I bet you if I told people it was
they'd bring me a cake so that's when
like an hour later I heard people
singing happy birthday and bringing him
a cake and he looks you know passed in
he gets he Winks at me like what the
[__] so the second thing that happened
was he came over to me we were on set
and and Dwayne was on setting he goes
just walks up to me and he'd always go
hey dude
and and I was like oh hi Christopher
Walken he goes do you know where I can
get a a nice Steam and I was like
um a steam he was yeah I would like to
get a nice Steam
so I said yeah hold on a second I went
up to Dwayne and go hey dude
um Christopher Walken wants a steam do
you know where where he could get that
he's like [__] am I supposed to know
where to get a steam I go I'm sorry
you're right so then somebody told me of
like a spot
um I go um Christopher Walken um there's
a place called Brook Williams and
apparently they have you know a place
where you could get a nice Steam and he
goes do you think there'd be a lot of
pretty men there
and I'm like
um sure I'm sure sure and he looked at
me and he winked and he walked away and
I was like
so then like like a couple weeks later
he walked up to me and he goes the
Rolling Stones are playing this October
I'm like holy [__] hold on a second I go
up to Dwayne go dude Christopher Walken
wants to go to The Rolling Stones with
us they're playing this October
and Dwayne looks at me goes
um dude it's it's November
and
then I went over and then he looked at
me and winked and you just walked away
that's what he would do all the time he
was just [__] with Sean William Scott
but the funniest part is Christopher
Walken like who the fact that you're
calling Christopher with me it was just
quick I went up to him I said I was
nervous should I call you Mr Walken
should I call you um uh Chris he goes I
don't know just call me flash
no way then he walked away and the next
day I tell the story many times and I
just said hey to my friend Anthony watch
us hey flash nothing flash nothing
finally tensor goes what you talking
what are you talking and walked away
what the [__] is
[Music]
good oh see you did the same thing with
you he [__] with me too but he [__]
with you a lot more